after almost three years of hearings and
evidence that prolonged their pain
families who lost their loved ones in
the Manchester Arena bombing arriving at
the inquiry one last time
it was set up to learn lessons and to
create changes after a series of
catastrophic Mistakes by a number of
agencies before and after the attack
a process the inquiry's chairman wants
to see continue we will not be going
away today passing ourselves on the back
and congratulating ourselves
we will only do that and we only can do
that if we do actually achieve lasting
change
in his inquiry Sir John Saunders
concluded the response by the emergency
services that lack was inadequate yet
even now first aid provision at large
venues is still unregulated a fact that
prompted this exchange wherever all of
this ultimately ends up in terms of the
precise form of the regulation if there
is a state of affairs in which routinely
thousands of people are going to venues
for events and they are risk of injury
and death as a result of a lack of
Regulation there needs to be some form
of Regulation
that must surely be agreed by your
department I I that is absolutely going
to be the question that we need to
answer after 201 days of evidence 283
Witnesses and 172
000 pages of documentation the inquiry
investigating what happened here six
years ago has now concluded but for many
of the families the fight for change
will continue our plea to the government
now is please don't forget us and our
loved ones names but do the right thing
in their memory
one of the people who died that night
was Martin hit his mother's campaign
that began as a petition is now a draft
bill in his name aimed at forcing their
news to prepare plans to prevent Terror
attacks none of us are immune for from
being caught up in the terrorist attack
and therefore it is absolutely necessary
to get Martin's law off the ground to
protect the General Public
this inquiry ended how it began
remembering the names of the 22 lives
lost
for the people that love them these
faces should be a reminder more action
still needs to be taken to stop other
families suffering like they have Shinji
marike Sky and use Manchester